ازمه ماليه طاحنه يتعرض لها مستشفى خمسه
سبعه ثلاثه خمسه سبعه الخاص بعلاج سرطان
الاطفال وتهدد باغلاق ابوابها فبعد ان
اغلق فرع طنطا من هذه المستشفى بشكل كامل
بسبب قله التبرعات وحتى دعم الماليه
الازمه تنتقل الى فرع المستشفى في القاهره
والذي قد يتم اغلاقها ايضا خلال الايام
القليله القادمه في ما ضجت مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي بالعديد من الصراخات والمناشدات
للمساعده في انقاذ هذا المستشفى من
الاغلاق في وجوه الاطفال
المزيد مع السلامه
[موسيقى]
مستشفى 57 3 57 اكبر مستشفى لعلاج السرطان
الاطفال في العالم مهدد بازمه الماليه
[موسيقى]
عام 2007 ويعالج نحو ثلاثه الاف طفل سنويا
مجانا وبتكلفه تصل اليوم الى 950 مليون
جنيه مصري كل عام نسبه الشفاء بين الاطفال
تقدر بنحو 71 بالمئه
[موسيقى]
مستشفى 57 3 57 يعتمدوا بشكل كامل على
التبرعات وفي السنوات الاخيره وبسبب بعض
الازمات الاقتصاديه منها ازمه فايروس
كورونا ارتفاع سعر الدولار والازمه
الاقتصاديه العالميه تقلص حجم التبرعات ما
ادى الى اغلاق فرع المستشفى في طنطا كما
تم تاجيل الخطط المستقبليه بزياده عدد
الاسره لاستيعاب عدد اكثر من الاطفال
عمر يوسف نشر فيديو عن هذه المشكله مناشدا
للناس العوده للتبرع حتى يستمر المستشفى
في تقديم خدماته
[موسيقى]
800 مش قادر خليهم 500 مش قادر خليهم 100
صدقوني الجنيه بيفرق معهم
[موسيقى]
على كل ينضم الينا من القاهره دكتور معتز
الزناتي المدير الطبي للمستشفى ونائب
المدير العام اهلا بكم دكتور يعني ازمه
المستشفى تتصاعد ومحاولات مش سميته
لاستقطاب تبرعات اولا كيف بدات الازمه ما
الذي حصل تحديدا
صباح الخير يعني انا احب في البدايه ان
احنا نتفق على شويه مسميات كده عندنا تحفظ
شويه ازمه احنا بنحب نسميه هنا تحديات ااه
ممكن ابدا باترودكشن سريع كده عن المستشفى
المستشفى بدات سنه 2007 في استقبال المرضى
همم طاقه استعمال 180 سرير همم المستشفى
من يومها لحد النهارده وهي بتتوسع وصلنا
في 2020 لطاقه الشعبيه 380 سريت وبقيت
اكبر مركز متخصص لعلاج اورام للاطفال في
العالم همم المستشفى لما وصلت للعدد ده
وصلت لهذا ال- ال- الطاقه الاستعمال
الكبيره همم بقى البردن والحمل الاقتصادي
على المستشفى كبير
والمستشفى كمان مرت من بدايه من 2015/2016
فبعد التحديات الاقتصاديه اللي حطت
المستشفى في همم همم في محكم ان هي محتاجه
تاخذ بعض القرارات للاستمرار في تقديم
احسن خدمه طبيه بالمجان للاطفال فال 2016
ظروف الاقتصاديه اللي حصلت وبعدها 2018
وحصل همم شويه هجوم اعلامي على المستشفى
همم وبعد كده الوباء العالمي الكرونه خلت
المستشفى همم محتاجه تاخد شويه بيزنس
دسجنز قويه للاستمرار في الميشن بتاعتها
بتقديم اعلى جوده للخدمه الطبيه للاطفال
مرضى السرطان والقرارات البيزنس والبيزنس
او القرارات اللي اتاخذت همم كانت كلها
لتخفيض التكاليف بدون المسافه بجوده
الخدمه الطبيه المقدمه للطفل همم بعض من
القرارات دي همم
هل اثمر اي تواصل مع الحكومه التواصل مع
مسؤولين بخصوص هذا التحدي كما وصفته الذي
يعانيه المستشفى
[موسيقى]
هو طبعا المستشفى مستشفى 57 هي تابعه
لوزاره التضامن الاجتماعي وضغط على
الاشراف من وزاره الصحه وكذا وكذا جهه
ووزاره في البلد
واحنا طول الوقت من يوم ما فتحت المستشفى
لحد النهارده في دعم وتسهيلات من كل
الجهات الرسميه المستشفى قائمه على
التبرعات وهمم ما فيش اي حد في الشعب
المصري ما تبرعش همم فزي ما باقول
المستشفى همم بتلقى الدعم من كل الجهات
الرسميه همم وتسهيلات من كل الجهات
الرسميه اا وهي قائمه على التبرعات وكل
الشعب المصري بيتر على المستشفى همم ومن
اول يوم من الكلام ده طب ده من كل يتبرع
دكتور يعني لماذا طلبيات من الادويه
والمعدات الطبيه الضروريه لم تصل للمستشفى
بعد
هي دي مش حاجه الخاصه بالمستشفى بس يعني
المستشفى
كجزء من مش حتى في مصر بس العالم كله
دلوقتي من ساعه الكورونا خصوصا والمشاكل
التي تحصل في الاستيراد والتصدير ااا في
مشاكل في الافيلا بليتي بتاعه الادويه في
كل المستشفيات العالم همم
مريض السرطان احتياجاته كبيره جدا من
الادويه احتجاجات كبيره جدا من المستلزمات
والتقنيات المتقدمه همم هي هو التحدي
الحقيقي في ان احنا محتاجين بالاعداد اللي
عندنا ان احنا نستمر في الحفاظ على نفس
المستوى دوله الخدمه المقدم ومع زياده
اعداد ومع تاثر
الحاله الاقتصاديه للعالم عموما الدوله
وللمستشفى بالتبعيه همم كل احتياج للتبرع
زاد فهو التبرعات موجوده التبرعات همم ك
كميات ما قلتش لكن همم احتياجنا التبرعات
اكثر في الفتره دي همم مطلوب علشان همم
القدره الشرعيه بتاعه المستشفى قلت عن قبل
كده همم
ما بتقدر توفره قبل كده بموردها وبالاضافه
لده زياده اعداد المرضى المسلمين اتحدث عن
ايام
كم هذه انتهاء هذه المده ما هو مصير
المستشفى
[موسيقى]
ان شاء الله عمره ما هتقفل يعني المستشفى
طول الدعم موجود طول ما الناس الجدعان
موجوده وبتتبرع على المستشفى ان شاء الله
عمرها ما هتقفل والتحدي الحقيقي بتاعنا
دلوقتي هو ان احنا محتاجين تبرعات علشان
نستمر في الحفاظ على نفس المستوى الخدمه
احنا المستشفى اخذت شويه قرارات لتقليل
المالي ده همم منها مثلا همم الطاقه
الاستعبايه بتاعه المستشفى قالت لان
الطاقه الاستيعابيه مش بس عدد اسره الطاقه
الاستيعابيه يعني توافر ادويه الطاقه
الاستعابيه يعني همم وجود همم كوادر بشريه
واطاقم طبي همم على اعلى كفاءه هيقدم خدمه
همم كل ده تاثر في الفتره الماضيه والطاقه
الاستيعبيه بالتالي فالمستشفى ابتدات تقلل
شويه في ال- ال- ال- ال- الطاقه الاستعلام
او يعني في في في اعداد المرضى التي يتم
قبلها همم كان في برده همم تم مراجعه
الطريقه التي يتم تقديم بها الخدمه للمرضى
همم المستشفى مثلا كانت قبل كده بتقوم
بمتابعه المرضى بعد الشفاء من السرطان
وانتهاء بروتوكول العلاج مدى الحياه احنا
حددنا دلوقت فتره المتابعه لخمس سنين بعد
انتهاء برود كل العلاج همم فالقرارات دي
بتحصل وبتحصل من المستشفى همم للحفاظ على
همم همم
يحصل شكرا جزيلا للاسف انتهى وقتنا شكرا
على تواجدك معنا